comme un air de déjà-vu si la question
avait enflammé les débats en mars 2020
fallait-il ou non reporter les élections
municipales
même interrogation aujourd'hui à un
détail près remplacer municipal par
régional le week-end dernier les préfets
ont sommé les maires de se prononcer sur
la question avant lundi midi puisque le
sujet est au menu des débats cette
semaine à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat
une manoeuvre qui a été perçu comme une
manipulation par une partie de
l'opposition
on est une fois de plus dans une
manipulation du gouvernement pour
reporter les élections
on est face à un gouvernement qui
cherche à se défausser de ses
responsabilités parce que s'ils sont sur
la logique de reporter ça veut dire
qu'une fois de plus le président de la
république a menti en disant qu'on met
les bars et terrasses vont rouvrir qu'il
a menti en disant que 30 millions de
français seront vaccinés au mois de juin
un son de cloche que l'on retrouve aussi
à gauche de l'échiquier politique
les maires ne sont pas des pions que
l'on consulte uniquement à des fins
politiciennes
les dernières annonces des manuels
macron sont claires réouverture des
terrasses et 30 millions de vaccinés au
15 juin
mais on interdirait aux français de
voter drôle de conception de l'état de
droit
il faut arrêter de manipuler nos
concitoyens certains en tout de même
plaidé pour le report du scrutin c'est
le cas par exemple du maire ait l'air de
nice christian estrosi pour qui la
campagne vaccinale reste la seule
campagne primordial toujours est il que
personne ne semble accorder ses violons
sur la question et le report de ces
élections pourrait se révéler risqué
pour la majorité à quelques mois de
l'élection présidentielle
être accusé de tripatouillage n'est pas
un bon signe donné aux électeurs la
majorité se doute bien que les résultats
ne lui seront pas favorables
autant s'en débarrasser le plus vite
possible et les autres partis ne sont
pas loin de penser la même chose
d'autant plus en promettant un retour à
la vie quasi normale en mai de son côté
le conseil scientifique suggèrent que
les personnes vaccinées soit sollicité
pour tenir les bureaux
il plaide également pour que le vote
soit tenue en extérieur des
recommandations balayé par l'aimais
bref l'association des maires ruraux de
france pour qui ces contraintes sont
incompatibles avec le fonctionnement
d'une commune rurale
même si à ce stade l'exécutif a indiqué
privilégier le maintien des élections
les 13 et 20 juin prochain seules des
raisons sanitaires impérieuse de nature
à compromettre l'organisation de la
campagne ou du scrutin pourrait le
remettre en cause a indiqué le premier
ministre
toujours est il que la question est loin
d'être réellement tranché et tout peut
encore arriver